and now a sneak peek of the new series
chucky
e.b white said that explaining a joke is
like dissecting a frog
you understand it better
but
unfortunately the frog dies in the
process
jake are you okay
uh
yeah i just i don't i don't think i can
do this do you have a religious
no
conflict
just
i can't stand this out of blood [ __ ]
oliver remind your [ __ ] business
look you can do this just make a
vertical incision down the length of the
abdomen like i showed you
sometimes the heart will go on beating
for a few minutes after death
[Music]
[Music]
everyone has a halloween they'll always
remember
and this
is jake's
[Music]
jake you into vintage no i'm in the
retro oh what's the difference about 10
bucks
fair enough
[Music]
look at that someone took the butcher
[Music]
knife hi
i'm chucky you want to play
[Music]
jake
are you okay i can't understand the son
of blood
[ __ ]
oh no jake that isn't quite right
[Music]
what happened to you jake
you used to have friends
don't forget your boy toy
[Applause] [Music]
okay
it's contagious isn't it laughing at
people
well guess what and now the joke's on
you
hi
i'm jackie and i'm your friend to the
end
what did you do
mommy says real killing is bad yeah well
mommy's full of [ __ ]
look around you it's the world series of
slaughter
[Music]
did you feel that
everywhere jake wheeler goes death seems
to follow
creepy doll just creeps me the hell out
it's kill or be killed everybody's gotta
choose
what's going on with it
you wouldn't believe me if i told you
chucky
he's gone
dude you have a secret style problem if
you only knew
[Music]
hey kid
i'm gonna go kill your sister
wanna come are you sleepy
you snooze you lose
you